so Dr pillude can you tell me what a
forensic anthropologist does
forensic anthologist essentially is
using the the methods of biological
anthropology in a medical legal setting
so we typically are called into assist
with identification and Analysis of
skeletal remains
and how does that come into play sort of
with what we're seeing unfold with Lake
Mead and these discoveries
these discoveries will require a
forensic anthropologist to to
investigate them since they would be
skeletonized and they are skeletonized
so the forensic anthropologists can look
at the skeletal remains and identify the
sex assigned at Birth the age the
stature and they can evaluate any any
sort of trauma or injury that might have
happened at or around the time of death
and so all of that will be really
important in identifying the individual
and also will assist in determining the
cause and manner of death and so last
time we talked I had emailed you photos
of this bone that a family provided us
they said they found this bone and you
gave me your opinion which was
that that the bone was a human femur
and we had discussed how there was some
confusion and it was not investigated as
a human bone it was investigated as an
animal bone
um now the park service is saying
they've given that bone back to the
medical examiner's office to investigate
your thoughts on that
I think it's great that they were able
to locate it and that it will be
investigated
um it would be as we discussed before a
tragedy of a missing person was never
identified because of this this error
um so so it's great that um the the bone
will be analyzed and potentially
identified as as somebody
does it matter that time is lost since
it wasn't investigated that way as soon
as it was found
okay
it shouldn't necessarily affect the
forensic anthropological analysis since
it was presumably a relatively old
um case anyway since the remains are
fully skeletonized that takes a little
time
um so as long as the bone was stored
properly and there was you know chain of
custody none of that should should
affect too much the the progression of
the case in a successful resolution
and sort of what I was looking into is
a mistake was made
and when it wasn't initially
investigated as a human femur and I
showed it to you I showed it to a couple
of other forensic anthropologists who
you all agree that there was no question
this was a human femur so sort of
what happens when a mistake like that is
made like what oversight is there for
medical examiners or forensic
anthropology what
hmm
it can vary
um so it can depend on the office and
sort of the standard operating
procedures that they follow and then it
can also vary on whether it's a coroner
system or a medical examiner system so
the corner medical examiner depending on
the county will oversee that death
investigation so they might have
policies in place for oversight within
their own offices like quality assurance
or peer review
um so so those sorts of things can can
try to you know help when help ensure
that mistakes aren't made and that if
they are that they're identified and and
rectified